[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen zu einer
kürzeren heute-Sendung in der
Halbzeitpause unsere Themen
Abschreckung und ein Signal an Putin am
Himmel über Deutschland beginnt ein
Großmanöver westlicher Luftstreitkräfte
Alternative zur Wärmepumpe mehr
Haushalte in Deutschland sollen mit
Fernwärme beheizt werden
Populist medimilliardär offroad-
trainieren für den Ernstfall in
Deutschland hat die internationale
luftwaffen-
es ist die bislang größte Übung von
Luftstreitkräften der NATO und weiterer
Staaten etwa 10.000 Soldaten und
Soldaten nehmen daran teil 6000 davon
aus Deutschland sie üben den
Verteidigungsfall mit 250
Militärflugzeugen dabei soll die
Zusammenarbeit der 25 beteiligten
Nationen optimiert werden
Transportmaschinen der
nato-einsatzbereit das Szenario der
Übung ein östliches Militärbündnis ist
in nato-gebiet eingedrungen und hält
Ostdeutschland besetzt diese Übung ist
im Signal gegen niemanden gerichtet es
ist ein Signal an uns an innen gerichtet
in die NATO hinein sind überwiegend
NATO-Staaten die an dieser Übung
teilnehmen die Deutsch geführt ist dass
wir in der Lage sind dieses Land und
dieses Bündnis zu verteidigen geplant
war die Übung lange vor dem Krieg in der
Ukraine am Morgen starteten mehrere
Kampfjets Richtung Litauen
das ist das was unsere östlichen
Bündnispartner verlangen diese
Rückversicherung dass wir zeigen auch
sie sind natürlich teilintegraler
Bestandteil dieser NATO die
verschiedensten Manöver werden bei eher
Defender trainiert von der Luftbetankung
bis zum Kampf gegen Drohnen und
marschlu-körper diese Übung findet ja
ganz bewusst auf einem Level statt der
nicht zu Eskalation beitragen soll
sondern es ist natürlich eine massive
Präsenz das ist auch wichtig ein
deutliches Signal gegenüber Russland zu
senden ein weiterer Punkt der Übung das
Schützen von Städten Flug und Seehäfen
wir wissen seit dem russischen Überfall
auf die Ukraine dass die europäische
Sicherheitsarchitektur so wie sie über
Jahrzehnte lang von uns unterstellt
worden ist eben nicht mehr funktioniert
durch die zahlreiche militärflüge wird
es enger im deutschen Luftraum
Einschränkungen im zivilen Luftverkehr
sind deshalb möglich
das schwedische
Friedensforschungsinstitut warnt in
seinem Jahresbericht vor einer
weltweiten atomaren Aufrüstung zwar ging
der Gesamtbestand der nuklearen
Sprengköpfe leicht zurück die Zahl der
einsatzfähigen Atomwaffen ist jedoch
wieder gestiegen um 86 auf
9.576
Russland und die USA haben die mit
Abstand größten Arsenale dahinter liegt
China insgesamt verfügen 9 Länder über
Atomwaffen
in Deutschland soll ja mehr mit
erneuerbaren Energien geheizt werden so
das Ziel der Bundesregierung jetzt hat
das Statistische Bundesamt mitgeteilt
drei Viertel der im vergangenen Jahr
fertiggestellten Wohngebäude werden ganz
oder teilweise mit erneuerbaren Energien
beheizt und es gibt jetzt Pläne das
Fernwärmenetz schneller auszubauen und
grüner zu machen Anja kapinos
hunderte Kilometer Rohre die Stadtwerke
Rostock versorgen darüber gut 60% der
Haushalte mit Fernwärme deutlich mehr
als anderswo den Netzausbau will die
Bundesregierung nun forcieren auf dem
fernwärmegipfel in Berlin heißt es mehr
Preistransparenz soll für netzkunden
kommen und Hausanschlüsse sollen
gefördert werden wir werden das
harmonisieren mit dem Gebäude
Energiegesetz so dass die BürgerInnen
wissen wenn ich in einem Bereich bin wo
Potenzial Fernwärme ausgebaut wird dann
habe ich darüber frühzeitig ein
Informationen und kann meine
individuellen Investitionen darauf
abstimmen kurz um wo es in den nächsten
zehn Jahren einen Fernwärme Anschluss
gibt muss nicht in andere Heizsysteme
investiert werden die zentrale Heizung
besonders für Großstädte geeignet das
Prinzip Wasser wird im Kraftwerk erhitzt
fließt meist durch unterirdische Rohre
in die Haushalte und von dort gekühlt
wieder zurück
bislang kommt ein Großteil der Fernwärme
aus Kohle Öl oder Gas die Umstellung auf
erneuerbare Energien sollen nun schnell
kommen für die Anstrengung fordern
Kommunen bessere Regulierung und mehr
Geld vom Bund es ist ein großer
Personalbedarf auch mit damit verbunden
diesen Prozess zu organisieren zu
steuern da würden wir uns wünschen dass
im Gesetz noch mal eine Aussage dazu
getroffen wird wer das dann finanziert
es ist ein Kraftakt für die ganze
Republik bis 2045 sollen Wärmenetze in
Deutschland klimaneutral sein
bei der Deutschen Bahn sind die
Tarifverhandlungen in die nächste Runde
gegangen die Eisenbahn und
Verkehrsgewerkschaft hat ausdrücklich
Streikbereitschaft signalisiert bei der
Bahn gibt man sich zuversichtlich in den
nächsten fünf Tagen eine Lösung zu
finden bei den Gesprächen geht es um
Löhne und Gehälter von gut 180.000
Beschäftigten
der US-Autobauer Ford setzt für den
europäischen Markt voll auf
Elektromobilität und hatten nun in Köln
sein Werk für E-Autos offiziell
eingeweiht zur Feierstunde kam neben dem
Urenkel des Firmengründers Henry Ford
auch Bundeskanzler Scholz ford hat
insgesamt rund 2 Milliarden Dollar
investiert und will ab Herbst
Elektromodelle für den europäischen
Markt produzieren allerdings werden
dafür weniger Mitarbeitende benötigt als
bisher bei Verbrenner
Silvio Berlusconi hat in Italien seine
Spuren hinterlassen er war der am
längsten amtierende Ministerpräsident
seit Gründung der Republik war
Milliardär Medienunternehmer gründete
die rechte Partei forza Italien jetzt
ist Silvio Berlusconi im Alter von 86
Jahren gestorben der russische Präsident
Putin bezeichnete ihn als echten Freund
nüchterner die meisten
Beileidsbekundungen aus der EU für
Mittwoch ist ein Staatsbegräbnis in
Mailand geplant ein Nachruf von Andreas
Postel
es war der letzte Sieg des Silvio
Berlusconi das von ihm geschmiedete
Mitte rechtsbündnis gewinnt 2022 die
Parlamentswahlen zwar wird Georgia
Meloni Ministerpräsidentin ihre extrem
rechte fratellit Italia stärkste Partei
doch in Cavaliere mischt wieder mit ganz
oben er prägt Italien über drei
Jahrzehnte
vom medienmodul zum Multimillionär bis
zum Ministerpräsidenten Italiens und das
viermal eine schillernde Karriere
angetreten war belusconi 1994 angeblich
um das korrupte Italien zu erneuern als
Politiker nutzte er hemmungslos seine
Medienmacht drei Privatsender gehörten
ihm Zeitungen Verlage und ein
Fußballclub mit seiner Vorzeit Italia
bestimmte er jahrelang die Politik des
Landes mit den mächtigen zeigte er sich
gern besonders mit Vladimir Putin den er
auch nach dem Angriff auf die Ukraine
als Freund bezeichnete immer wieder
geriet er mit dem Gesetz in Konflikt die
Vorwürfe Bestechung Betrug und
Steuerhinterziehung doch nicht die
Skandale und wilde Bunga Bunga Partys
sondern die Wirtschaftskrise verursacht
auch durch jahrelang verschlepptere
Formen treiben ihn schließlich Ende 2011
aus dem Amt
Silvio Berlusconis Anhänger glauben er
habe sich für Italien aufgeopfert seine
Gegner er habe das Land für seine
Interessen ausgenutzt was bleibt ist
eine beispiellose Karriere die wohl so
nur in Italien möglich war
[Musik]
nach Österreich in den Bergen dort ist
ein ganzer Gipfel weggebrochen
mindestens 100.000 Kubikmeter Gestein
donnerten zu teil und zwar am
fluchthornmassiv bei Galtür in Tirol
nach dem Bergsturz so rauschten auch
Wassermassen herab niemand wurde
verletzt wahrscheinlich hatte der
schwindende Permafrost das Gestein
gelockert das Eis sei der Klebstoff der
Berge erklärte ein Geologe dieser
Klebstoff gehe jetzt langsam verloren
die nur top-möller wird neuer Trainer
des Fußball-Bundesligisten Eintracht
Frankfurt erhält ein Vertrag bis 2026
für den 42-Jährigen ist es der erste
Cheftrainer Posten in der Bundesliga er
war zuletzt Co-Trainer von Julian
nagelsmann beim FC Bayern und in Leipzig
vor 30 Jahren war sein Vater Klaus
Trainer der Eintracht
hochsommerliche Aussichten gleich von
Katja horneffer das heute journal können
Sie am 21.45 sehen mit annek und jetzt
geht's weiter mit der zweiten Halbzeit
im Fußball Länderspiel Deutschland gegen
die Ukraine
[Musik]
guten Abend das spannendste in diesen
Tagen sind die Temperaturen sie sinken
in dieser Nacht auf 16 Grad am
Niederrhein und besiegen gerade in
Oberfranken oder auch am alten Rand
morgen gibt es wieder viel Sonnenschein
und nur hier im Osten einige Wolken
fällt oder der winterzug kommt das
östlichen bis nordöstlichen Richtungen
die Temperaturen steigen auf 20 Grad
hier im südlichen Brandenburg und bis
auf 29 Grad am Niederrhein im Westen
ändert sich an diesem Wetter auch in den
nächsten Tagen wenig im Osten gibt es
einige Regenschauer und Gewitter bei
Temperaturen von 19 bis 28 Grad tschüss